[Music]
there's a problem with X inflation that
X's have gotten really expensive so the
2600x for example is 50 more than the
2600 non-x but the 7900 XTX is it ends
up being so the 700 XT is 33 fewer X's
at 10 less money
clearly one of the worst downgrades in
PC history ever review over we can all
move on now
X inflation aside and video did AMD a
massive favor by launching its 4080 at
1200 and 40.90 at sixteen hundred
dollars and the most interesting aspect
of our 7900 XTX review was the fact that
the 4080 is 1200 bucks so you end up at
a thousand for the 700 XTX and 900 for
the 700 XT that we're reviewing today in
this video and at the time of filming
Nvidia hasn't budged we'll see if they
do they probably will at some point
because there's a lot of them sitting on
the shelves even here in Taipei but for
now the 4080 it remains uh not really
that that good of a value so we're
reviewing the 700 XT we're still on the
other side of the world from our usual
Studio but we have all the usual data
for you let's get started before that
this video is brought to you by crucial
and it's ddr5 memory for Intel or AMD
ryzen CPUs crucial makes ddr5 kits that
are Deployable and ryzen 6000 laptop
systems and in ryzen 7000 systems or
Intel they're like including both budget
oriented and performance-based memory
modules if you're building a new system
click the link in the description below
to learn about crucial ddr5 memory this
video is going to be more of a test for
our editors than a test for the cards
with all the highlights and all of the
different x's and the product names so
bear with us and the chart highlights
for this one but we're going to do our
best there's the XTX that we reviewed
and then as we call it sometimes the XT
non-second act we have a lot more we
want to do with these cards when we get
home to analyze the data closer but
today we're focusing on gaming for
rasterization we'll also be looking at
Ray tracing hello at raytracing
performance Hawks for asterization out
here in Taipei and uh we'll be looking
at Thermals power and some fan and
frequency response Behavior today for
some quick references the 900 7900 XT
puts it above the 6950x10 price and the
6900 xtn price with those two still
right now today as I'm filming in the
650 dollar Mark and we saw them up to
about 700 so that's probably the closest
competition for AMD right now is its own
parts from last generation for some
quick specs so the RX 7900 XT steps down
to 20 gigabytes of memory from 24
gigabytes on the 700 XTX with the stream
processor count dropping from 6144 to
53.76. those are big changes for a
hundred bucks memory bandwidth also
drops to 800 gigabytes per second from
960 gigabytes per second partially a
result of turning off one of the six
mcds the full die has one gcd or a
graphics compute die and 6 mcds but the
7900 XT moves to a dummy die plus five
mcds now the dummy die is just for
stability and keeping the cooler Mount
consistent doesn't do anything although
it may be fused off in Silicon and not a
pure dummy we're not sure in the XCX
review we also went over pressure maps
flatness and we went over a transient
spikes which you go check out if you
haven't seen it but for this one let's
just start with some some of the
benchmarks and get into gaming right
away our first Benchmark is one we
reserved for the 7900 XT it's a unique
one we've spent years refining it and we
don't think you're going to see this
data anywhere else on the internet we've
got it locked down at this point this
chart shows the number of x's in a
product name with higher obviously being
better as shown here the future XFX RX
7900 XTX has more X's than it has other
letters in its name at five we counted
this name four times to make sure we got
it right so this testing is just as
accurate as our other tests the AMD RX
7900 XTX only has three X's allowing XFX
a lead of 67 percent to X's that's as
many X's as Ace attack has for liquid
cooling Partners so it's a lot the 700
XT is a step down from that still at
just two x's this means that an extra
100 gets you fifty percent extra X's if
you move to the XTX as for NVIDIA the
Nvidia RTX 4090 only has One X and
egregious oversight that we can't
believe we missed in our original review
with the XFX rxxtx I had a 400 lead
extra X's honestly the review is kind of
over before it even started X we'll step
down to less important testing with
power benchmarks looking at average
power consumption during a workload it's
not as good as the x's and the number of
them but for this one we ran transient
tests against the rx700 XTX and our XTX
review so check that video out for
oscilloscope shots like these and
background information on Transit
handling and voltage regulation for the
700 XT we just focused on the nominal
power consumption during a constant load
though here we saw the XT pulling 313
Watts when stock or 362 Watts when
overclocked this is using the stock amdb
BIOS with a maximum power offset so it's
as far as it can go for this cart the
362 watt number puts it just past the
351 Watts or the 700 XTX which itself
jumps to 416w Watts when overclocked the
stock 313 watt figure is alongside the
6900 XT which pulled 300 watts for its
workload and it's below the 6950 XD at
377 Watts that means that even if AMD is
equal to the 6950 XT and some tests for
gaming results it'll still at least have
better power consumption figures
thermals are up next and this testing we
ran benchmarks using specialized 3dmark
render scenes for a sustained gaming
load the GPU is allowed to hit steady
state by running for 30 minutes and
leveling out its fan curve before
averaging hundreds of rows of data the
RX 7900 xdx reference card had some
issues here and its main problem was
coil wind that we showed in the XTX
review its memory temperature was a
secondary problem and noisy fan ramp
with bad hysteresis was the tertiary one
here the rx700 XT continues the trend of
only being somewhat acceptable the 700
XT is 88 degree memory Junction is
bordering on unacceptable as installing
this card into any case that's
sub-optimal for cooling the GPU we'll
push those memory thermals close to the
spec limit the real problem is that the
fan on nearly all gpus except EVGA icx
spins based on GPU temperature only as
long as the GPU is cool and this one is
doing pretty well here the fan won't
spin up fast enough to accommodate the
memory alone GPU thermals have the edge
temperature at an average of 57 degrees
Celsius and the hot spot at 72 degrees
for the gcd those numbers are both fine
here mcd4 is disabled on our 7900 XT and
all XTS will have one MCD turned off it
just may move around which one it is
ours again was four but the rest of the
McD temperatures are all fine and in the
60s and there's no Inlet sensor on the
XT so that's not shown here fan response
is up next plotting the GPU Edge
thermals we see they Spike to 60 degrees
before the fan intersects the
temperature and cuts it back down to 56
degrees Celsius the hot spot is about 72
degrees so both are operating in good
territory the fan ramp is still too
small spiky though the XTX had the added
problem of spiking initially and then
falling off and then spiking again the
XT spikes instantly to about 1800 RPM
and then fluctuates in the high 1700s
during the test Andy needs to do some
fan ramp tuning on both of these cards
this card also has coil wine issues
although we didn't bother recording this
one like we did for the XTX the
frequency validation is next tested in
the same scenario the 7800 XTX
originally plotted in the 2600 to 2700
megahertz range with some occasional
spikes higher the RX 7900 XT had a
similar trajectory it jumped to 25 30
megahertz and then fluctuated plus or
minus 60 throughout the test there were
occasional spikes to 2700 megahertz but
none that mattered and they were overall
few the frequency spec is 2400 megahertz
so at least in this test AMD is hitting
its advertised clocks well starter
gaming benchmarks with rasterization as
always and will begin with Total War
Warhammer 3. this time we're skipping
the 8K test Justin because clearly in
our XTX review 8K was definitely worth
everyone's time and we're glad that AMD
spent all the time it did marketing
something that is so playable and
something that everyone has anyway at 4K
the RX 7900 XT non-second X ran at 75
FPS average meaning that spending 100
for an extra letter X is in this game
worth the 20 uplift versus the
non-second X that's a large jump for a
hundred bucks sort of but it's not
always that clean as you'll see in some
of our other games this number is all
over the place and like Nvidia it starts
to more look like the classic upsell the
XT lands between the 3090 and the 3090
TI outperforming the RTX 3080 by about
18 the 4080 still isn't worth buying at
least at the price it was when we wrote
this review but as a comparison it's 16
ahead of the XT non-second X that's
that's the 7900xt clear the 7900 XT out
does the 6900 XT by 40 generationally at
average FPS or 29 over the 6950 XT now
don't get too excited about these
numbers because they drop down a lot
again depending on the game we'll get to
those against the previous gen Flagship
5700 XT any of these modern gpus would
be a serious upgrade the 700 XT is
included in that list and just remember
that at some point you're moving from
old enough Hardware that all the options
will feel significant even if they
aren't the most expensive on the market
prices as of a week before the launch of
this card are still very good on last
gen Hardware so you should be looking
around at 30 series and 6000 series
stuff as well at 1440p the 700 XT ran at
155 FPS average establishing the XTX as
about 16 percent ahead of the XT that's
reduced from the 4K Delta we saw which
we think has to do with some combination
of memory bandwidth and the one inactive
McD the 3090 TI falls behind the 700 XT
here once again establishing that the
3090 TI's recent launch was a last
minute grab for gaming users it at least
had some value for people who were using
it for the video memory though the lead
of the XT over the 3080 is about 35 FPS
average here or 29 compared to the 6900
XT of last gen the 700 XT pushes a 36
Improvement that's for the 4080 it's
still tactically ahead the 4080 that is
but the 1200 MSRP means that 88 of the
performance is achieved at 75 percent of
the price finally at 1080p the 7900 XT
pushed to 233 FPS average allowing the
700x TX and 11 lead reduced from 20 at
4K and 16 percent at 1440p so there's a
clear downtrend here as resolution
decreases the 4080 still has a lead over
the 7800 XT although again it's not only
that's anywhere near justifiable at the
price as for older Hardware the 6900 XT
is available at time of writing for 660
dollars or seventy three percent of the
MSRP of the 700 XT and 75 percent of the
performance AMD has at least improved
generationally against the launch MSRP
but it's older cards for as long as
stock lasts remain competitive with the
new options the 4090 establishes the
ceiling here and it's the Undisputed
leader AMD hasn't changed that with its
launch with these two cards although AMD
has further damage to the perceived
value of the 4080 with the XTX at least
in rasterization Ray tracing Nvidia is
still in the strong lead Tomb Raider is
next starting at 4K we wanted to see if
AMD could repeat the XTX to XT Gap it
achieved in Total War in this one the
XTX is 143 FPS average against the XT is
123 FPS average establishes about a 16
lead for the XTX four percentage points
reduced from Total War but close enough
to remain significant it's kind of where
this one lands AMD is positioning these
cards similarly to nvidia's top two so
rather than a slight overclock that
nearly invalidates the flagship like we
used to see there's kind of a real swing
that's starting to form here but that
extra 16 costs 11 more money for
reference and this is a clear push to an
upsell as GPU prices in general climb
upwards the 4080 keeps about a 20 lead
against the XT for its 33 price hike
against the 6900 XT we're looking at a
swing of 104 FPS average to 123 FPS
average on the XT it's not the biggest
generational swing and nvidia's lack of
presence at a thousand dollars and below
is really the biggest thing that AMD has
going for it right now with this card
the card is obviously nowhere close to
the 490 performance but it's also
nowhere close in price so fair enough
and someone has to sell something below
a thousand dollars at 1440p the XT is
215 FPS average creates only an eight
percent gap between the XT second X and
the actually no second X but one first
ax the 4080 and 40 90 aren't that
interesting here they're outperforming
the limitations of this Benchmark at
1440p so we'll look down the stack
instead the 700 XT out does the 6950 XD
by about eight percent here making the
6950 XT or 6900 XT a better value if you
can buy at the new and lower prices
assuming they're still available when
this video goes up eight percent is
little more than a pre-overclock so it's
basically just a refresh at that point
except way too expensive against the
3080 the XT has a 31 Improvement it's
not worth buying a new GPU if you
already own a 3080 but it may be worth
eliminating or at least reconsidering
the 3080 in a raster Focus gaming PC
we'll skip 1080ps into two CPU bound to
be useful Final Fantasy still has good
scaling at 4K making it a surprisingly
interesting Benchmark since it
represents an otherwise underrepresented
category of gaming MMOs and it scales
beyond the CPU with some settings the
7900 XTX is 148 FPS average gives it a
19 Improvement of the rx7800 XT similar
to Total Warhammer the 4080 is a click
above that at 152 and against the 6900
XT we're looking at a more limited
uplift of 20 to 10 depending on if
you're considering the 6950 XD instead
so that 10 number against the 69.50
that's really not exciting
generationally for the 700 XT and it's
clear that the XT might mostly exist to
push you towards the XTX again similar
to the 4080 to 40 90. next up is F1 2022
this one is a limited data set due to
game updates that required full reruns
recently the rx700 XT ran at 143 FPS
average allowing the XTX a lead of 15
the 4080 leads the XT by five and a half
percent here as for last generation the
6950 XT is 133 FPS average put the 700
XT 7.6 ahead so nothing it basically
just feels like that we overclock again
if this particular Trend continues it'll
be shaping up in a disappointing way for
the XT but Total War was one of the more
positive results so we'll see how it
unfolds at 1440p for F1 it's even worse
the 700 XT only leads to 6950 XT by
three percent at 233 versus 226 FPS
average it's starting to feel entirely
pointless the 6900 XT and the 6950 XT
cards were just available for hundreds
of dollars cheaper so Andy's asking in
this game for three percent more
performance but for over 30 more money
the new in box 6000 series cards that
just sold recently Rainbow Six looks a
little better at 4K the 700 XT outpaces
the 6950 XT by 19 or the 6900 XT by 28
the XTX leads the XT by 19 here and the
4080 is also about 19 ahead as it's tied
with the XTX if the 4080 ever comes down
in price it may pose an existential
threat for some AMD 7000 series cards
but it depends on how much it comes down
we just saw dozens of them on shelves in
taipei's biggest Electronics market so
we'd imagine the price drop is looming
Rainbow Six Siege at 1080p had the 49d
clearly CPU bound and the 4080
occasionally bound during The Benchmark
that means we're not able to see full
scaling the 700 XTX and the 700 XT
remain comparable to each other though
there's about a 1.4 percent benefit on
the XTX to the XT or about five percent
over the 6950 XT from the 7800 XT but
that was at 1080p so there's clearly
something going on with the 700 XT at
1080P and Rainbow Six that just makes it
not beneficial to use at least compared
to something like any of the other cards
we just talked about our last non-rt
gaming Benchmark is Horizon zero Dawn at
4K for this one the 700 XT ran at 101
FPS average which has the XTX about 19
ahead unfortunately for the XT it's
about equal with the 6950 XT and only 11
percent ahead of the 6900 XT the 700 XT
seems mostly dead in the water in this
type of scenario as long as the last gen
guards still exist on the market
although the XTX remains an interesting
Contender that's worth considering the
700 XT sometimes posts large gains over
last gen but in this case it's just not
enough to really consider you can save a
lot of money by stepping down to the
6950 XT and basically lose nothing in
this specific scenario Ray tracing
performance is next on our list of tests
and videos managed to set up a foothold
here and it has kept better positioning
versus AMD but this area is still new
and results are varied and we only test
a few games for this one right now
cyberpunk can control where the two top
voted games by our community when we
recently asked on the YouTube Community
which RT games people play and they have
wildly different results between AMD and
Nvidia in cyberpunk at 4K and with dlss
and FSR at equivalent set ends between
the vendors the rx700 XT ran at 37 FPS
average to the xt-axis 41 FPS average
result that's about an 11 lead for the
XTX compared to Nvidia it has the 700 XT
about equal to the RTX 3080 in this
particular game and just behind the RTX
3090 those are similar to The 3080 as
well and the 4080 has a strong lead at
58 ahead with a 4090 obviously ahead of
that at 1440p and with the same settings
The raytraced cyberpunk Benchmark
positioned to the rx700 XT at 68 FPS
average so effectively tied with the RTX
3080 and RTX 3090 the XTX offered a 14
improvement over the 700 XCX non-second
x with the 4080 61 percent better than
the 700 XT Tomb Raider with Ray tracing
is far easier to run just remember that
these charts are different from our
earlier Tomb Raider tests because we're
now enabling RT Shadows the rx700 XT
operated at about 68 FPS average here
tied with a 39 DTI this time this is
better relative positioning because most
of this test remains rasterized where
AMD does better than in its RT Pure
Performance the XTX is 15 better than
the XT in this test at 1440p in the same
test the rx700 XT is 125 FPS average
gave the XTX a small 12 lead hardly
interesting compared to the results with
a wider range the generational lead is
at least better at about 21 over the
6550 XT the 7900 XT pulls ahead of the
3090 TI in this one with thanks to the
resolution reduction which helps it and
simplification of Ray Trace Graphics
down to just Shadows control is the
other highly voted game from our
community using a heavier workload and
Tomb Raider but a lighter one than
cyberpunk it also avoids amd's known
issues with cyberpunk right now where
AMD itself has talked about them the 4K
control Benchmark without any DLS as or
FSR technology has the 7900xt 39 FPS
average given the xdx an improvement of
16 over the 700 XT and that's at 45 FPS
for the 1 000 option versus the 900 for
the XT the 700 XT is therefore behind
the 3090 and the 3090 TI this time and
roughly tied with the RTX 3080s 38 FPS
average result they're within error of
each other here the 6950 XT is not
though and it's 31 FPS average result
means a generational uplift of 24 here
at 1440p the XT is now at 82 FPS average
which has it between the 3090 and 3090
TI the XTX is about 14 ahead as is the
3090 TI with the 4080 establishing a 29
lead proportionally the 700 XT is
looking better here than it did in some
other games with its 3080 lead of 10
percent so in total the 700 XT is a
peculiar card it's really weirdly
positioned we think it's more useful to
AMD as an upsell than it is necessarily
as a 900 video card at this point
because the XCX sometimes it's like 20
ahead which is massive for a hundred
dollars but then at other times the
value just really isn't there especially
compared to the 6900 XT and the 6950 XT
where if they're still available when
this video goes up at 650 bucks
they're pretty compelling versus the 79
XT even though the XTX has a more
meaningful uplip and a lot of that is
because in some of the games we looked
at the 6950 and the 6900 XT it's like a
one to four percent Gap versus the 7900
XT it just depends on the test and
obviously other times it's far far more
than that but the fact that it's a
little variable here is part of the
problem now we've moved away at this
point Nvidia and AMD both from the days
of having a flagship that's four percent
better for 400 more now they have
flagships that are actually meaningfully
better than their second best card but
there's still a price hike there so it
seems the companies have realized they
can sell a lot more of these high-end
flagships if they end up pushing them
farther apart rather than closer
together where it was almost an inverse
upsell in the Titan era or some of the
ti class cards like the 2080 TI versus
the 2080 we didn't see gaps like this
back then there's a quick recap you
might be better off saving a few hundred
bucks on the 6000 series if there's
anything left if this point but the ray
tracing performance does pose
significant gains against the 6000
Series in the 7000 series so if you
really care about RT you still need to
look at the 7000 series or more
realistically Nvidia AMD is still behind
in Ray tracing performance and it still
has a fighting chance and rasterization
so that hasn't changed generationally
the XTX manages to bounce the 48 out of
the second rank regularly giving it hope
if Nvidia sticks to its high price point
the 700 XT is worth it sometimes and
pointless other times entirely depending
on the test and some of that comes down
to how much memory bandwidth versus
compute it's using so for the 700 XT we
really can't get behind this one the XTX
makes more sense where it is there's a
little bit of price creep in here
generationally for both vendors and
these not as steep as Nvidia So that's
its strongest point right now is the
4080 at 1200 still doesn't make any
sense and that XTX does actually post
some pretty meaningful gains versus the
6000 series it's just the XT non-second
X that ends up being more of the problem
so so it feels like the XT is a little
too expensive for what it is in
aggregate even though in Total War for
example it looks pretty good and uh
ultimately we're analyzing this remotely
so just as a quick note there's more
work we want to do once I get back but
for today we're limited to what we're
able to do on the other side of the
world for a review and that means that
there's probably some data analysis some
comparison versus marketing things like
that that you'll have to see in a future
video from us because it's very hard
working on a laptop and the Airbnb where
there's construction going on
surrounding us the GPU is allowed to hit
steady state by running for
[Applause]
so that's it for this one thanks for
watching subscribe for more as always
we'll see you all next time